y divulgación de difamación con impacto
en el prestigio del país o promover la
indisciplina social solamente por
mencionar algunas de las leyes hacen
parte de esta nueva norma tiene estándar
internacional para proteger la
ciberseguridad o simplemente se puede
considerar como censura
bueno muy buenas noches santiago y la
verdad es que esta es una normativa que
nos preocupa de acuerdo a estándares
internacionales de libertad de expresión
en primer lugar por lo que dicen porque
no hay referentes no hay digamos
estándares que acojan que por ejemplo el
prestigio del país que es algo que de
cierta manera apela a los contenidos que
los y las usuarias pueden poner internet
sea un aspecto protegible por los temas
de seguridad nacional estamos hablando
de un decálogo bastante amplio de
asuntos que entrarían a ser limitados
como por ejemplo daños calificados como
éticos o sociales
ecos mediáticos a noticias falsas
mensajes ofensivos y esto también tiene
que pasar proyectamos el deber que tiene
el estándar de las autoridades de ser
tolerantes a la crítica creemos que es
una normativa que puede ser regresiva y
que puede generar un efecto inhibitorio
la libertad de expresión sobre asuntos
de interés público señor vaca esta norma
incluye también una larga lista de
aspectos informáticos como daños físicos
usted mencionaba algunos acceso difusión
grafía infantil que están catalogados
allí dentro de esta ley como de
peligrosidad media pero la categoría de
subversión social que estamos comentando
es de alto riesgo no hay aquí una
desproporción en el manejo de los casos
santiago aquí hay una clasificación
sobre el impacto y la peligrosidad de
ciertas conductas muchas de ellas pueden
terminar
criminalizando expresiones legítimas
dentro de una sociedad democrática de
acuerdo a estándares internacionales de
derechos humanos por ejemplo también
entraría en esta órbita de
criminalización los contenidos que
puedan llamar a movilizaciones y aquí va
la segunda preocupación y es la
institucionalidad que entraría a
interpretar y aplicar este este marco no
porque estamos hablando de una
institucionalidad que en la cual no se
advierte en frenos y contrapesos donde
además hay una
clara homogeneidad en la forma en cómo
se percibe cuando hablamos de un sistema
por ejemplo que tiene solo medios
oficiales bajo qué estándar se va a
medir la falsedad o la veracidad de un
contenido es muy complicado no lo quiero
llevar al terreno político pero está el
gobierno de cuba reaccionando muy tarde
ante el impacto que ya tuvo el uso de
las redes sociales entre los cubanos que
consiguieron
para los mismos ciudadanos para estas
marchas difundir las imágenes alrededor
del mundo de lo que está pasando allí y
cómo fueron reprimidas estas marchas lo
que le quiero preguntar es si esto es
imparable esta ley a mordaza por
completo a los cubanos o simplemente ya
llega muy tarde
yo creo que es una ley que es grave por
lo que dice es una ley que es grave por
la institucionalidad que entre a
interpretar la dice una ley que además
es grave por el momento no puede por
todos y todas conocidos las protestas
que iniciaron el pasado 11 de julio y el
lugar que tuvo internet incluso las
restricciones que se denunciaron sobre
internet y entonces está entras en un
instrumento que lejos de acercarse por
ejemplo al diálogo que fue sugerido por
distintos organismos internacionales
empieza a tensar la situación ciudadana
con un sacrificio enorme y un efecto
inhibitorio para las futuras sanciones
que puedan sufrir los cubanos por lo que
publiquen en internet y en distintas
redes sociales